very much thanks for joining us and good  luck in the remainder thanks a lot and  uh shaq  has just made a move  oh he went to b3 okay he went to b3  bishop g6 oh no oh no no no he's happy  with that takes queen d6 he'll go king  at seven  and claim that  he is in fact doing okay  because how are you going to put and  i'll have a he's a deposer and  something like that  yeah i would suspect that it's now we  are now well under the realm of tactics  but um  that that would be the logic because i  don't see why it was necessary it was  not called foreign  okay  wow  well we have to see magnus's reaction to  this because it's somewhat of a  surprising roof  it is still very hard to win after that  but uh  look upon the pawn  it gives you hope as well well bishop g6  k6 queen  d6